in Prince Harry's Long battle against
the British press this is likely to be
the most dramatic chapter so far but on
day one of his case against mirror group
newspapers it was his absence that was
most notable his lawyer David Sherborne
said the prince had flown from the U.S
overnight having attended his daughter's
second birthday and would give evidence
on Tuesday the judge expressed surprise
the opposing lawyer said it was
extraordinary and a waste of the Court's
time given that he intends to
cross-examine the prince for a day and a
half
that will be a rare event say Royal
observers both an opportunity and a
moment of Jeopardy so the idea of Prince
Harry being cross-examined in court by a
very very experienced lawyer who knows
that if he starts being needled he will
start to say things which are going to
be harmful to his own case for a day and
a half I mean his absolute you know box
office Blockbuster stuff and you think
to yourself for risks of that as an
approach incredibly High Harry's is one
of four representative cases picked from
more than a hundred individuals who are
suing mirror group newspapers one of
Britain's biggest newspaper Publishers
for allegedly unlawful journalistic
tactics ranging from phone hacking to
deception to use of private
investigators mgn denies using such
tactics in 28 of the 33 Stories being
considered in Prince Harry's case and
says they aren't admitted in the
remaining five at the beginning of the
trial it did admit to unlawfully gaining
information about him for one story in
2004 and apologized when he got to the
substance of his arguments Prince
Harry's lawyer accused mirror group
newspapers of failing to put forward any
of their journalists to defend their
tactics so that they had destroyed
evidence and said that they'd already
admitted on one occasion using unlawful
tactics against Prince Harry and that it
was implausible to think that they
hadn't done so multiple times
for Prince Harry this has become a
personal Crusade against what he sees as
widespread criminality and intrusion
within the British media one with its
roots in the treatment and ultimately
the death of his mother Princess Diana
in 1997. he spoken publicly of parallels
he sees in the coverage of his wife
Megan a victory would justify the
prince's high-profile campaign but as
his day in court approaches fellow
members of the royal family may be
wondering at what cost Harry Fawcett Al
Jazeera London